Ostriches can be trained to herd sheep.
A hammerhead shark can be rendered completely
immobile for 15 minutes by turning it over
and tickling its tummy.
The muscles that close a crocodile's jaws
exert a force equivalent to a truck falling
off a cliff, but the muscles that open them
are so weak that they can be kept shut by
a rubber band.
If a tree were planted for each Coca-Cola
sold, we could reforest the Earth in three
years.
Placebos are 30% more effective as an antidote
for depression than drugs.
Katujjiqatigiittiarnirlu is Inuktitut for
'simplicity'.
The inventor of 'Best before' dates, which
were originally used for milk, was Al Capone.
When playing with female puppies, male puppies
will often let them win, even if they have
a physical advantage.
Before the Renaissance, three-quarters of
all the books in the world were in Chinese.
In 2011, the Internet reached 13.7 billion
pages: one for every year since the Big Bang.
WTF is the acronym of the World Taekwondo
Federation.
99% of Austrians are German, though most Austrians
insist that they aren't.
Only 35% of the average person's Twitter followers
are actual people.
27,000 trees are felled each day for toilet
paper.
About 200,000 academic journals are published
in English each year.
The average number of readers per article
is five.
An adult produces enough hydrogen in their
urine each year to drive a car 2,700 kilometres.